ولكن هذا يقودني إلى التساؤل في
حالات أخرى حيث الأشخاص الذين يتم
قتلهم بالرصاص ليسوا في الواقع
رهائن إسرائيليين بل هم في الواقع فلسطينيون. هل كانت
سياسة جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي حتى الآن هي
إطلاق النار على الأشخاص الذين من الواضح
أنهم مدنيون فلسطينيون
لأنهم  الفلسطينيون، كما قلت،
مثل هذه الحوادث هي
انتهاك واضح لقواعد الاشتباك، إن
قواتنا لديها مهمة واضحة للغاية
للتمييز بين المدنيين
وبين المقاتلين. تحاول حماس أن تجعل
ذلك صعبًا قدر الإمكان، ليس في
هذه الحالة ليس في هذه الحالة كان تبادل إطلاق النار
هو هذا.  يقول جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي إن تبادل
إطلاق النار انتهى بهؤلاء الرجال الثلاثة الذين
تركوا وراءهم، لذا فقط أجب على
سؤالي هل تم إطلاق النار عليهم لأن جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
اعتقد أنهم
مدنيون فلسطينيون، وهذا ما حدث، جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
يحقق في الحادث لا أستطيع
التعليق عليه هذا  كان من الواضح خطأ فظيعا
فظيعا